welcome to the 2013 graduation ceremony
at Stanford University's Graduate School
of Business what you have accomplished
at the GSB you have not accomplished
alone first you're sitting
shoulder-to-shoulder with your
classmates as you have throughout your
time here you have forged bonds here
that will become lifelong friendships
which will nurture and sustain you in
the years ahead
in the time-honored tradition you have
declared yourselves to be friends of RJ
Miller it would be remiss of me if I did
not say how honored we are to have with
us the Vice President of the United
States I have left the most important
for last this is your opportunity to
stand and say thank you to your friends
and family who are celebrating your
mutual accomplishment yet today please
join me in giving a warm GSB welcome to
John Donahoe I want to share with you
four simple leadership principles that
I've learned over the past 25 years
these timeless principles have helped me
navigate my work in my life and I hope
they're helpful to you Linc your work
with a sense of purpose never stop
learning the most valuable learning
often comes in difficult times build
your full life not just your work life
having completed all of the academic
requirements of the program this year 80
Sloan fellows will join the worldwide
family of Stanford Business School
alumni the Ernest C Arbuckle award is
presented to a second year MBA student
who is nominated and chosen by his or
her peers the recipient by his or her
active participation initiative
leadership and personal integrity is
seen as having contributed most to the
fulfillment of the goals of the Graduate
School of Business I am delighted to
present this year's Arbuckle award to
the momma bear of section 6
Stephanie collect
congratulations Stephanie
yeah Alexander robichek student
achievement award in finance is given to
an MBA student selected by the finance
faculty not only for outstanding
achievement in but also for their
contributions to the finance courses
this year's recipient of the robichek
award is Jackson Gorton from the RJ
Miller scholar 'he's one students
achievement places him or her at the top
of the class this student is designated
as the henry ford ii scholar this year's
recipient of the award is Stuart Phillip
Lynn
I wish you the courage to continue to
dream and to soar no matter what
obstacles are put in your way I hope you
will stay as tightly knit as you are
today and that you will continue to
support one another in your aspirations
I'd like to ask all other graduates to
please stand one last time and be
recognized
you